retour en salle des conférences ici la
salle qui jouxte l'hémicycle se déroule
le ce débat je suis avec Laurence
Rossignol bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vice-présidente socialiste du Sénat
ancienne ministre des familles et les
droits des femmes un mot sur ce qui se
joue dans l'hémicycle depuis 14h30 on
voit cette série d'amendements qui
présente une alternative dans le
financement au régime des retraites et
votre rapporteur général votre
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse qui
vous accuse d'utiliser ces amendements
pour avoir une tribune dans l'hémicycle
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez écoutez
le Parlement est une tribune pour tout
le monde y compris pour la droite et la
majorité bien sûr que nous avons des
choses à partager avec les Français
tout le raisonnement qui fonde le report
de 62 64 ans de l'âge de la retraite et
fondé sur l'idée qu'il y aurait un
déséquilibre démographique mais il y a
plusieurs façons de d'envisager ces
questions de déséquilibre on peut
comparer le nombre d'actifs le nombre
d'inactifs on peut comparer le nombre de
cotisants le nombre de pensionnés puis
on se peut aussi comparer la richesse
produite
et le nombre de pensionnés les gains de
productivités qui ont marqué les
dernières décennies ils ont compensé le
fait qu'on ait moins nombreux à cotiser
ils peuvent ils peuvent tout à fait
compenser le fait qu'il y a moins
d'actifs qu'il y a d'inactif aujourd'hui
je donne un autre exemple si les femmes
étaient payées comme les hommes il n'y
aurait plus aucun sujet sur les
ressources de l'assurance vieillesse que
dire aussi de ce qu'a dit René Paul
Savary dans l'hémicycle et lorsque et
bien il dit que vous faites de
l'obstruction finalement au fait qu'on
avance plus vite que cela dans ce texte
écoutez c'est un texte très important
j'ai envie de dire que avec plus d'un
million de personnes déjà dans la rue
plusieurs fois depuis un mois
notre temps de parole doit être
proportionnelle au mouvement que nous
représentons et par ailleurs nous ne
faisons pas d'obstruction tous les
sujets que nous abordons sont des sujets
qui tiennent et qui sont liés et
directement impliquent la réforme des
retraites qu'on est en train de discuter
nous ne lisons pas les pages du
dictionnaire au micro nous travaillons
sur une réforme nous faisons valoir nos
alternatives nos alternatives nous
faisons valoir nos critiques et nos
propositions ce matin c'est peut-être
l'information de la matinée c'est le
vote par le Sénat de cette mesure
proposée par la droite et le centre d'un
CDI senior la gauche a voté contre
pourtant avec un mauvais taux d'emploi
des seniors autour de 56% pour les 54 64
ans on se dit ça pourrait être une un
bon outil pour peut-être favoriser
l'emploi de ces seniors alors nous
l'avait appelé le CDI dernier embauche
par référence au CPE contrat premier
embauche
effectivement
par le gouvernement
en fait nous nous méfions terriblement
de ces exonérations de cotisations ce
sont des milliards et des milliards
d'euros qui sont impactés qui impactent
le budget de l'État le budget de la
protection sociale et qui contribue
d'ailleurs à ce qu'ensuite on vient de
dire il y a plus assez d'argent qui
rentre donc ce contrat dernier embauche
ce contrat senior que propose le
rapporteur il est encore fondé sur des
nouvelles exonérations de cotisations et
par ailleurs si le gouvernement et le
Parlement doivent discuter de mesure
nouvelle pour l'emploi il faut le faire
avant la discussion sur la réforme des
retraites puisqu'il faut avoir en tête
l'impact correspond et mesures sur
l'emploi pour pouvoir ensuite envisager
quelle est l'application des portes
pictives sur les retraites et là le
gouvernement parle d'une loi travail au
printemps donc vous vous dites on a des
choses à l'envers ils ont fait les
choses à l'envers ils vivent mieux valu
mettre la loi travail en hiver et
peut-être qu'on serait rendu compte
qu'il y avait plus besoin après la loi
travail de réformer la je la retraite il
nous reste une minute pour discuter
encore d'un sujet c'est la mobilisation
de demain on a pris que vous alliez vous
rendre vous les sénateurs de gauche via
une délégation dans les cortèges c'est
quoi c'est l'idée de soutenir de dire
que il y a les échanges entre ce qui se
passe ici au Sénat et de ce qui se passe
dans la rue demain d'abord pour beaucoup
d'entre nous nous avons déjà fait les
manifestations moi je les ai faites dans
mon département tantôt à Compiègne
tantôt à Beauvais les autres les en fait
pareil dans leur ville et certains
d'entre nous se sont toujours rendus à
la manifestation à Paris donc il y a
rien de nouveau demain de ce point de
vue là nous nous y rendrons comme nous
nous y sommes rendus bien entendu nous
sommes les relais les portes-parents du
mouvement social c'est nous qui
traduisons en termes parlementaire dans
la confrontation avec le gouvernement
vous savez les les syndicats je crois
que j'ai entendu dire que le l'Inter
syndical j'ai entendu Laurent Berger ce
matin que la terre syndicale n'avait pas
été reçu en tant que tel par le
gouvernement nous nous avons la chance
de pouvoir interpeller le ministre ici
au Sénat et porter au ministre ce que
nous disent les représentants syndicaux
et les citoyens qui manifestent tous les
regards vont se tourner vers l'examen de
l'article 7 celui sur la mesure d'âge
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut aller
vers un examen de cette mesure après les
manifestations par exemple quelqu'un qui
serait les manifesté qui rentreraient
chez lui qui allume République Sénat et
qui pourrait avoir ce débat là c'est ce
qui va se c'est demain côté le rythme
d'examen dans au Sénat enfin au
Parlement et quelque chose d'assez
aléatoire et pas toujours prévisible ce
que je peux dire c'est que l'article 7
sera examiné au Sénat nous débattrons de
l'article 7 et il sera soumis au vote
c'est une demande désorganisation
syndicales à laquelle nous répondrons
positivement j'ai une dernière question
si vous voulez bien à Laurence Rossignol
mais il y a eu ces débats autour et bien
de la réforme Touraine vous étiez membre
du même gouvernement que Marisol
Touraine on entend que effectivement la
droite vous renvoie cet argument sur les
43 annuités qu'est-ce que vous répondez
aux Français qui disent effectivement ce
sont les socialistes qui ont mis cette
barre à 43 ans c'est vrai d'abord les
les rapports du corps parce que
maintenant tous les Français connaissent
leur apport du corps les rapports
en 2014
le rapport du corps donné des des
prospectives et des prévisions de
déséquilibre des finances de la retraite
qui était bien différente de celle celle
de rapport du corps d'aujourd'hui ça
c'est la première chose et puis dans la
réforme torrent il y avait aussi le
dispositif carrière longue et les
critères de pénibilité que le
gouvernement Macron s'est dépêcher de
d'amputer dès 2017 quand il est arrivé
au gouvernement et bien merci merci pour
toutes ces explications merci au micro
de Public Sénat nous on va rejoindre
[Musique]